Gillette is shaving away toxic
masculinity in a new ad campaign we will
examine the true causes of toxic
masculinity toxic femininity and
everything in between
then President Trump hosts a fast food
feast at the White House Laura Loomer
illegally immigrates to Nancy Pelosi
house and Kamala Harris pulls a Liz
Warren I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
get ready for a lot of toxic Michael
initi today you're gonna get a heavy
dose of it there aren't enough Gillette
razors in the world to shave all that
away
but first let's make a little money
honey with expressvpn with all the
recent news about online security
breaches it is hard not to worry about
where my data goes making an online
purchase or even simply accessing your
email could put your private information
at risk you're being tracked by like
every single person on the internet
social media sites marketing companies
your mobile your internet provider
that's why I decided to take back my
privacy with expressvpn expressvpn has
easy-to-use apps that run as seamlessly
in the background of your computer phone
or tablet turning it on takes only one
click you need to do this it seems like
something so it doesn't really matter oh
my dad are there just out there no you
can secure your data it's very
inexpensive it's very important to do
this don't leave yourself vulnerable
expressvpn secures and anonymizes your
internet browsing by encrypting your
data and hiding your public IP address
and if you're watching this show I can
only imagine what else you're looking at
on the Internet protect yourself with
expressvpn for less than seven bucks a
month find out how you can get three
months free at expressvpn comm slash
michael mi CH AE l that's expr e SS VPN
dot-com slash michael mi CH AE l for
three months free with a one-year
package expressvpn dot-com slash michael
mi CH AE l to learn more you let you've
probably seen this Gillette has a new ad
out I'm gonna show this ad in its
entirety you're not gonna want to miss
one little bit of it it's a new ad about
toxic masculinity they've jumped on the
social justice warrior bandwagon here it
is if you've missed it
bullying the meter movement against
Africa's masculinity is this the best a
man can get
is it we can't hide it's been going on
far too long
[Music]
we can't laugh at all
[Applause]
what I actually think she's trying to
say making the same old excuses but
something finally changed and there will
be no going back because we we believe
in the best in men men need to hold
other men accountable for our sweetie
come on to say the right thing to act
the right way not cool not cool
saman already are in ways big young men
oh [ __ ] and smoking are you strong
parallel
but some is not enough some we treat
each other better
because the boys watching today
[Music]
we'll be the men of tomorrow Gillette
the best a man can't get so this ad just
notice all of the subtle left-wing
social justice warrior aspects to it
just to begin one point that not a lot
of people are talking about is that with
one exception for the first 40 seconds
of the ad all of the bad guys are white
guys with one exception of they're
probably 50 or 60 guys you know whole
lines of guys and the cartoons and all
this and with the exception of one bad
black guy all of the bad guys are white
guys and then when it turns and it's
good virtually all of the good guys were
saying hey don't do that be nice to this
person don't believe this person are all
not white guys and they did this because
they are they are feeding into not just
a narrative about men should be nice to
women they're feeding into an
intersectional narrative they're feeding
into the main narrative we see now on
the Left which is that there are
hierarchies of victimhood and the worst
guys in the whole wide world are the
straight white men who think that
they're men and who behave like men
should behave this comes on the heels of
the American Psychological Association
saying that traditional masculinity you
know as opposed to that newfangled
masculinity is is harmful it's terrible
we need to get rid of it
so Gillette is buying into this I
actually was I was late to the show
today I was late getting to the studio
because I woke up and I had to take
photos of of well me shaving before I
used my Gillette razor and then me after
I use my Gillette razor and you can see
the difference right on-screen if you
can't you know in the first picture I'm
I'm wearing a wife-beater you know I'm
kind of that's that that's just what
they call it it's a men's undershirt
that's just the phrase talk about talks
like and you know my hair is askew I've
gotten smoking a cigar and drinking
scotch at 7:00 in the morning and then
but after I used that Gillette go home
it was just amazing I transformed into a
plaid onesie
I had a little tea cup with a little
lemon drop
on the side and I just I felt so much
better you know so clearly this product
is working the
show response to this is what
self-respecting man is going to buy a
razor for a company that is lecturing
and scolding men with this ridiculous
caricature of masculinity which is
buying this line hook line and sinker
that masculinity is a bad thing fair
enough I I do think it will hurt them in
the long run but what your let is doing
is they're looking around especially at
Nike and they're saying Nike by
embracing radical left ISM by embracing
Colin Kaepernick as their spokesman by
embracing these anti-american anti
traditional politics they they got a
short-term gain at least a short-term
gain in sales profits market you know
they've they've they've actually done
pretty well as a result of that campaign
and Gillette is looking at that and
they're saying that right now in the
sort of normal society politics is
downstream of culture culture is
downstream of religion but in this weird
society that we're in now it's like a
snake eating its own tail
politics is still downstream of culture
but then culture is downstream of
politics in a way that the left is
totally inverted so they look to the
politics not just as their culture but
is their God and they're saying okay
well if that's the case then we need to
infuse our advertisements with politics
now it's a little weird for Gillette
because Gillette is a company for men
men skew more conservative than women
we'll see if this pays off for them in
the end the idea that itself though is
just so wrong because I've seen even a
couple of conservatives on Twitter say
oh I don't really see what's wrong with
the ad they're just saying men shouldn't
be jerks they're not saying that men
shouldn't be jerks they're saying that
men are jerks there's it's not just the
men should be nicer men should be more
polite sure yeah of course what they're
saying is that men by their very nature
are awful they're worse than women
they're they're just bad people who do
bad things and and further what they're
saying
by using these extreme examples and they
used to get these kids low roughhousing
kids are wrestling on the ground kind of
smacking each other and in the in the
bad olden days when people were using
Gillette then that was just boys will be
boys so
it's not a big deal but now in the good
days where Gillette is the new feminist
shaving company then the father goes and
he says no we don't roughhouse no we
don't do that this is the way to raise
the worst kind of men
if you tell boys not to stick up for
themselves
not roughhouse every once in a while not
to be able to take a punch every once in
a while they are going to be so weak
they are going to be so embittered they
are going to be so stressed and anxious
and depressed and catty and miserable
that they're going to look like young
men do in our current society because
that's exactly what happened you had a
generation of men raised broadly with
the self-esteem movement with anti
masculinity or toxic toxic masculinity
with feminism as the dominant ideology
and er ideology of their youth and what
has this raised it's raised not a
generation of polite wonderful
chivalrous gentlemen it's raised a
generation where we now have allegedly
according to the left a rape epidemic on
campus we now have women claiming to be
abused in all forms of industries
obviously in show business and elsewhere
you raise men without any of the virtues
what what they are saying now is that
masculinity is toxic in reality
manliness is a virtue in fact it's not
just a virtue its what virtue means
virtue vr-2 is comes from Latin from vir
which means man and virtue
it means moral uprightness doing the
right thing this as the left always does
they have flipped this they have totally
perverted this and they want you to
believe that vices virtue and virtue is
vice the way you know this is all so
ridiculous because nobody's denying that
certain primarily male attributes of
masculine attributes can be perverted
and taken to a bad place
so courage can be turned into aggression
or bullying or recklessness or whatever
it can it can be turned into any of
those things but isn't that true of
every other group
what about femininity why don't we talk
about toxic femininity if I if I came
out and I talked about talk
SiC femininity I would be labeled a
bigot or a sexist or a misogynist or
whatever friend of mine posted on
Facebook the other day it was a picture
and she said you know I've been stopping
mansplain errs for a very long time it
was her giving a talk and said I'm
stopping man Splinter's what if I posted
a picture of myself at one of my college
talks and I said I've been shutting up
women since twenty sixteen or twenty
throw whatever would that look good
would that be a good look no of course
not and it doesn't work when women do it
either by the way what Gillette is about
to learn is it's actually already coming
out right now I think was Fast Company
published a headline after this this
advertisement it said Gillette targets
toxic masculinity in a new campaign but
still advertises on Fox News mm-hmm and
and what the idea here is is that
Gillette is pretending or there at least
feigning to be this social justice
warrior company now this is their new
marketing flip but they are not totally
social justice whereas they're still
advertising with Fox News they don't
advertise on our show but they they
advertise on a right-wing Network or a
vaguely conservative network and this is
very bad the lesson here is that you
will rue the day when you grant the
left's premises even if the premises are
seemingly convenient or expedient or you
think oh it'd be just so easy if I could
just if I just accept this premise
they'll stop bothering me okay men
masculinity is toxic you should all be
feminists the minute you grant that
premise like a snake eating its own tail
they will devour you there's also you
grant that premise but it's not good
enough it's not social justice enough
it's not leftist enough it's not this
and and this is really gonna come come
at Gillette it doesn't stop this
happened in Hollywood the minute that
actually it's it's happened in the me2
movement when these guys a lot of them
are pretty bad hombres in Hollywood
admit that they did something wrong or
they say maybe we I should wear the
little bracelet or the pin that says
time's up
the immediate
it just cascades it's an avalanche
Gillette I hope discovers that because
it's a it's a very bad thing it's a
horrible message it's a horrible message
in part because it's convincing to
ignorant and shallow people but
manliness is a virtue manliness is where
we get the word virtue and we should
defend that against these straw man
absurd attacks now let me invite you
into my boudoir speaking of toxic
masculinity and talk about one of my
favorites purple mattress you know that
I am a proselytizer for purple mattress
I kid you not I'm not saying this
because I'm doing an advertisement for
them almost every night I get into bed
with sweet level of ASA and we say ah I
love our purple mattress I'm so this is
really the perk of working at the daily
wire they haven't paid me in years and
years but at the very least I get my
cool purple mattress it is the best bed
I've ever slept on I simply love it
it's different than a memory foam it's
different than a an innerspring it's
this technology developed by a rocket
scientist it feels both firm and soft I
know that sounds contradictory it's not
it's just the best it feels great
I snooze my alarm 20,000 times in the
morning because I don't want to get out
of bed it's that great it also sleeps
pretty cool because of this this
material so you're not gonna be hotter
than you want to be which happens with
some mattresses you get a hundred night
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return it for a full
refund you won't return it back by
10-year warranty free shipping and
returns do yourself a favor
get this mattress it's just phenomenal
you're gonna love it right now my
listeners get a free purple pillow with
the purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just do this right
now
text Kofi facio vfe fe2 47 47 47 that's
the only way to get this free pillow
text cough FAC o VF EF e - 47 47 47 co v
fe fe two four seven four seven four
seven message and data rates may apply
speaking of toxic masculinity I'll
illustrate this point a little bit by
looking at some rhinos in the sad sad
case of John Kasich John Kasich now that
he's leaving the Ohio governor's mansion
is joining CNN surprising exactly not a
single person on earth he's joining CNN
and he is a pathetic politician he's
true
pathetic he started out John Kasich as a
pretty right-wing politician pretty
right-wing governor he was he was a
member of Congress Budget Committee
whose fiscal Hawk pretty rock-ribbed I
really liked him I was hoping he would
run for president in 2016
back when he was old John Kasich and
then he became this virtue signaling
leftist awful politician there was a
great peace today in the Washington
Examiner called John Kasich exits stage
left by Jason Hart
what is his legacy this is and I this is
my defense of manliness of being manly
and not being a weak wimpy RINO like
John Kasich he's leaving the Ohio
governor's mansion with super majorities
in both houses of the Ohio General
Assembly and yet the fiscal Hawk is
leaving with the highest government
spending ever Medicaid enrollment way up
low private-sector job growth lower than
the national average for a long part of
his tenure he also he was running
against the unions and the pensions he's
leaving with some of the worst union
laws in the country
one of the worst municipal tax systems
and some of the worst unfunded
liabilities in the nation so all of
those entitlement and pension programs
really awful what happened to this guy
he exhibited true toxic masculinity
which is wimpiness which is
self-interest John Kasich and only knows
about numero uno he doesn't seem to put
his ideas first or his constituents
first he's only in it for himself I
think is the reason why he's he turned
out so bad and he's clearly gotten bad
advice I mean this this was a decision
when he was first running he said I was
tea party before there was a tea party
he was running to the right and then he
got bad advice some people told him to
turn left that that was going to be his
path to more political power and he sold
his political soul for nothing because
that's what happens when you sell your
political soul if you get nothing it's a
bad investment read a book read history
read the Bible so what
this toxic masculinity paired up it's a
pairing of pure self-interest and and
ambition you've got to be really wary
about this this because I think this is
how leftism spreads in our culture is
people are purely self-interested and
they're very ambitious and so they're
willing to make a deal with the devil
they're willing to say well you know
look if I speak the truth if I say that
men aren't women if I say that up is not
down if I say that unborn baby is not
just a medical tissue as some activists
are saying today if I say that it will
hurt my career I might not make as much
money I might not be as popular at the
parties maybe I won't
I won't be as cool I won't be such a
cool guy and so they make these little
tiny concessions they make these little
social concessions in what happens the
culture is utterly transformed by wimps
even guys on the right you'll see this
sometimes I mean this is the classic
example of the Republican but not that
kind of Republican it's those guys who
you say oh you're a conservative and
they say yes I'm a conservative but I'm
much more interested in you liking me
than being conservative or advancing my
ideas I'm not that kind of a
conservative that's what they say and I
say you know look I get it I remember
I've gone through political evolutions
in my life certainly I was less
conservative when I in my youth when I
was sowing my Wild Oats than I am now
I get it there's a huge social pressure
on campuses in corporate America in the
halls of Congress to not be a real
conservative guy to not say what you
think to him you might be unpopular you
might you might sound out of fashion
just stick to it
otherwise you're left with nothing I
think it was it was Dean in who said the
man who marries himself to the spirit of
the age will find himself a widow in the
next and that's what's happening right
now John Kasich is mourning the death of
his political career he really could
have been a contender in 2016 if he had
remained a conservative render
Republican he now thinks he's gonna
primary Donald Trump in 2020 good luck
pal great I hope he does I think it'll
really unify the base around Donald
Trump to see this wimp this pathetic
of a politician go out and and run his
mouth about what what is he fighting for
all the things he was fighting for he
betrayed so he's just fighting for his
own pride and that's what it is it's
pride it's not just you on Kasich you
see this in you see this with an old GOP
operative named Steve Schmidt who's now
left of Vladimir Lenin and running to
make the people at MSNBC like him please
like me like me guys
Yuri is on MSNBC talking about Trump's
oval office speech you consider that
speech what a powerful argument it makes
against the theory of evolution as we
look at the continuing to basement of
the office of the presidency of the
United States we saw from Trump today
the typical lying
the racial demagoguery the nonsense the
spinning of crises out of whole cloth
they will reopen the government and at
that point what will become clear is
that even the Republican minority in the
house the Republican majority in the
Senate will have joined every world
leader most of the American people as a
group who do not take this man seriously
at all they look at him as a joke a
clown and a farce a joke a clown in a
forest don't take him seriously at all I
think Steve Schmidt is projecting I
think he he was looking at a mirror and
thought that he was looking in at an
oval office speech this is a man who
worked for John McCain he worked for
George W Bush and so he does come from
the the more squishy wing of the
Republican Party it's not you know like
he was going out there marching in the
Reagan Revolution he's a little young
for that he wasn't a founding member of
the Tea Party or anything like that
either but just to illustrate what a
squish what a what a what more weakness
what toxicity this displays this guy
Steve Schmidt left the Republican Party
he finally left to the Republican Party
and it's being talked about as though he
left it specifically over Trump but it
wasn't just Donald Trump the reason that
Steve Schmidt left the Republican Party
specifically is because Donald Trump
kept his campaign promise which was the
campaign promise of Barack Obama
it was the campaign promise of George W
Bush to
move the US Embassy in Israel to the
capital of Israel which is Jerusalem
when Donald Trump did that not when he
lied not when he said something racially
insensitive not when he exceeded his
powers of the executive when Donald
Trump kept his promise and the promise
of Steve Schmidt's own boss who didn't
keep that promise that was what made
Steve Schmidt leave the Republican Party
because he would prefer wimpy girly men
who lie who don't keep their word
because it's nice and it's polite and
that way a group of people in the Middle
East who elected Hamas to represent them
who elected a terrorist group to
represent them maybe then they'll like
Steve Schmidt see guys I'm cool I'm not
that harsh on terrorism or don't you
like me like me please it's pathetic
it's pathetic and it comes from Pride it
comes it ultimately comes from pride
because this guy just needs to be liked
you got to be a little careful about
politicians who are desperate to be
liked to look a little bit of seeking
out the applause and seeking out crowds
that is a professional hazard of
politics and show business it's a it's a
requirement of it really but you've got
to differentiate between the people who
are willing to say tough things and
don't care if you know the crowds around
them don't like them and the people who
are willing to change what they say to
any given audience no matter how the
political winds turn that's the
difference I mean you look at somebody
like Mitt Romney and any room he talks
to at any different day of the week that
he talks to he says something different
he's trying to appeal to them he's so
desperate for their affections it comes
from a pride and it comes from a
ruthless ambition that's truly toxic but
that has nothing to do with manliness
Steve Schmidt that's not a manly man
that's like that's a weak guy taking
potshots because he's betrayed his own
principles and he's left with nothing
he's left with nothing but the corpse of
his political career same as John Kasich
we will get to a good version of
masculinity probably Gillette wouldn't
like it very much but I certainly liked
it the Donald Trump fast foods
sumit the fast-food feast at the white
house last night with Clemson we'll get
to Laura Loomer illegally immigrating to
Nancy Pelosi's house 2020 Kamala Harris
campaign and then if we have time to
talk about Steve King but first I have
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube but and by the way this Friday
this is a really important event ben
shapiro the big boss himself will be
taking his show on the road to the March
for Life in DC he will be doing his show
from the March for Life it's going to be
very cool 10:00 a.m. Eastern he'll be
live-streaming at the National Mall and
12th Street so if you are planning to be
at the March head over there and see him
in person it's gonna be really
unfortunately I'm gonna be stuck here in
LA because someone's got to keep an eye
on the shop well the boss is out of town
you know someone's gotta smoke cigars
and everyone's studios and offices so
I'll have to be here if I could be there
I would if you're around town do not
miss it it is gonna be fabulous if
you're on Facebook and YouTube go to
daily wire.com ten bucks a month $100
for an annual membership you get me that
the end or Clavin show you have the Ben
Shapiro show you get the amount wall
show you get to ask questions in the
mailbag get them in that's coming up on
Thursday you get to ask questions in
backstage we were doing that a lot more
these days you will get to see another
Kingdom you'll get everything and you'll
get this you will get the leftist tears
a tumblr and this is very important
because you know sometimes when people
shave they use water you know they use a
faucet maybe they use shaving cream but
if you have the leftist here's tumblr
you can just pour this salty leftist
tears all over your face and it's the
perfect aftershave it stings a little
bit cuz I'm kind of cause of how salty
it is but it it just gives you a
beautiful scent all the rest of the day
you could just smell you get to maybe
stick your tongue out just taste the
most delicious leftist Cheers it will
set your day off right first thing in
the morning go to daily wire calm get
your leftist tears after shave tumblr
and we will be right back with a lot
more
every time i fleetingly think that I
don't love Donald Trump he does
something like this he invited the
Clemson football team over to the White
House to celebrate their win in some
sporting event that I did not even know
was occurring and apparently this was a
big deal and the trouble is the
government has shut down so there was
nobody there to cook all the food and
serve all the food so Donald Trump
rather than canceling the event he had a
stroke of genius he and by the way to
talk about Providence at work here
Donald Trump caters the whole event with
fast food last night McDonald's Burger
King Wendy's Pizza you know just all of
this fast food on silver platters with
chandeliers with candles you know is so
beautiful last night before this
happened before I saw this I was driving
home and I actually don't eat McDonald's
that much and I had a hankering for
McDonald's and I drove about a mile out
of the way or two miles out of the way
to go get it and I go I don't know why
do I want McDonald's right now if you
doubt Providence we just remember that I
think this is this is going to be the
new proof of the existence of God here
is Donald Trump using this event with
political brilliance be very interesting
you see at the end of this evening how
many are left
I like them all if it's American I like
it it's all American stuff so but it's
good stuff but we have the National
Champion team as you know Clemson Tigers
and they had a fantastic game against
Alabama
we have peaches we have 300 hamburgers
many many french fries all of our
favorite foods I want to see what's here
when we leave because I don't think it's
going to be much reason we did this is
because of the shutdown we want to make
sure that everything is right so we sit
down we've got this and we have some
wonderful people working at the White
House they helped us out with this and I
will say the Republicans are really
really sticking together it's great to
see because we need border security we
have to have it we have to have it no
doubt about it should have happened 30
years ago 20 years ago 10 years ago and
it's gonna happen now gonna happen now
thank you very much everybody never this
is the rule this has been you know never
get into a fight with a Sicilian when
death is on the line never engage in a
land war in Asia and never challenge
Donald Trump to a battle in the media he
is the master of the media so what he
did there was this event on the calendar
to hang out with the Clemson football
team and he says okay we'll still do it
and I will take this event and I will
turn it into an instantly viral
promotion advertisement for my border
wall during the government shutdown so
the news they've been covering how awful
he was how awful the Oval Office speech
was it's terribly tried that they hated
that so then he goes out and he creates
an event that even his opponents can't
hate there was a photo of him going
around sort of smiling in front of this
beautiful long table filled with silver
trays of hamburgers and they were all
joking even his opponents were joking
they said this is the Hamburglar look at
him look at this going this is so crazy
and so they're attacking him but they're
attacking him for doing something that's
we all have affection
for that's really very likeable it's
very hard to dislike Oh Cassio Cortez is
good at this too she's very good at
doing things that even her critics when
they point them out have to admit or
sort of likable you know she smiles she
giggles whatever and so Donald Trump
does this just to a whole nother level
and you'll notice there wasn't a lot of
Chipotle at that event
not even Taco Bell which I like it was
all-american he said it's all good
American food and what this did was this
triggered the left you know in a way in
two ways first they said they attacked
his wealth they said he's obviously not
a billionaire because if he were a
billionaire he'd have good food instead
of that disgusting fast food so he he
gets them and this was going all over
the internet all over the comment area
he gets the left to position themselves
as privileged effete rich people looking
down on people who have less than them
the the next part which is related to
that is he got the left to attack fast
food but the thing is that food that was
on that table in the White House is the
most popular food in America by a
longshot it's not even close like it's
not the the gap between Big Mac and kale
from Whole Foods is like there isn't
enough room in my studio to show the gap
in popularity between those two things
now the trouble is when you're talking
about members of the press the media
Democrats in Congress and the Senate
that exactly flips they haven't eaten a
McDonald's hamburger since they were 15
they only eat the kale from Whole Foods
and so and they pay much more for the
kale from Whole Foods for a little piece
of lettuce
than they do for a Big Mac meal at
McDonald's and so you have them looking
down on it you have the rest of America
saying wait a minute I love that that
sounds great they're all saying how
awful how awful it is that Donald Trump
invited the football team and he just
served them fast food that's disgusting
and the rest of America the rest of us
as I'm sitting there literally eating a
double quarter-pounder with cheese as
this is happening saying I love that
food that food is delicious what are you
talking about then they try to attack it
from another angle they say wow Donald
Trump he's playing into a stereotype
that college jocks like to eat a lot of
fast
dude well guess what all the food was
gone by the end of the night you know
why because college jocks love to eat a
lot of fast food not just college jocks
every college student likes to eat a lot
of fast food not just every college
student most Americans do it was a it
was a masterstroke because the as every
one of those little memes was going
around of Donald Trump standing in front
of 300 AM burgers you then have that
video going around Reese's yep the
reason we're doing these hamburgers is
because of the borders shut down but
that's okay I'm not going to complain
I'm not going to complain and this is
another aspect that he's demonstrate he
doesn't always demonstrate it but he's
demonstrating it here of manliness of
masculinity is you need gratitude you
need gratitude you know you need
humility Trump actually you know
ironically he does have humility he
jokes about him so he makes a lot of
jokes about bragging but he also makes
jokes about himself he says the only
good thing about me is I don't drink
I'd be the worst drunk in the world I'd
be the ID be terrible right he makes
these jokes about himself even as he's
joking about how funny he is how great
he is that whatever Itchy is and you
need a little bit of gratitude though
and he's saying look I'm not gonna
complain that we got to eat this food
everybody likes fast food it's our
favorite food it's good an American
we're gonna have a great time here
tonight that makes you a bigger person
it makes you a much better person it to
be a man you need to be able to look
back on your history on your forefathers
on everything in civilization that has
led you to where you are and you need to
not hate it if you hate it you become
whiny and miserable like the left
you become catty like all of these girly
men on the left wing but if you look at
it with gratitude you say look those
guys weren't perfect and his their
fathers weren't perfect and their
fathers weren't perfect and I'm not
perfect I'm sure not perfect I can
conclude I can deduce that I'm a flawed
person too that gives you a little bit
of humility and it allows you to look
forward and say okay here's how we're
gonna be the bigger man here here's how
we're gonna be adults here's how we're
gonna move forward it makes you much
more attractive this was a a real PR win
for a president who is who is losing the
PR battle of this shutdown his approval
rating is going down not by a lot but by
a little bit and his he's being blamed
overall for the shutdown
his policy is improving in popularity
the border wall itself is now more
popular than it was before the shutdown
but he needed a little PR win he totally
got it here and coincidentally it helped
to demonstrate a little lesson about
masculinity very much in the news you're
even gonna see this now so they make fun
of the airport the the fast-food you're
gonna see this with the airport's two
Americans are not being affected by the
shutdown they don't feel it federal
workers we feel bad for them you know if
they're out of work but that's a small
percentage of the population but your
vast majority of Americans are not
affected by the shutdown with the left
and the media are saying is well if the
TSA stops showing up to work if my
pre-check line at Terminal B at JFK is
shut down then you're gonna hear about
it mr. president
most people don't fly that much the vast
majority of Americans don't fly very
frequently the media fly around all the
time I fly around all the time I'm very
angry when the pre-check is shut down at
Terminal B of JFK but a small price to
pay from a small group of people who
generally inhabit a pretty privileged
segment of society and if they're gonna
be complaining about that it's gonna be
exactly the same thing you're have the
vast majority of America saying oh
you're your pre-check line was closed
boo-hoo-hoo let me play you a sad song
and the world's smallest violin big PR
win and and president Trump needed it so
that was very glad to see it last night
another fun PR win from the right was a
Laura Loomer if you're not familiar with
Laura Loomer she is a provocateur a
provocate ryx I suppose she would be
she's an investigative independent
journalist she's a right-wing activist
she goes a little out there sometimes
she can be a little out there this
however was perfectly executed she
illegally immigrated to Nancy Pelosi's
compound she was just going to go in
there you know because California is a
sanctuary state Pelosi said walls are
immoral so she's just gonna go in there
and it since walls are immoral she's
gonna live in Nancy Pelosi's house
surprise surprise she was met by Nancy
Pelosi as security guards
well this is private property so I'm
confused I thought that California
hasn't seen Tracy I don't know I thought
Nancy musi Pelosi we get ID from
everybody that's here since you guys are
on private from we don't need that in
California we don't need driver's
licenses because it's like a form of
profiling you're on private property and
you're trespassing so Nancy Pelosi said
Nancy Pelosi said that I didn't think I
needed you guys I'm really confused
because the sp Pelosi said asylum is a
human right but now they're saying I'm
trespassing and Nancy said everyone is
welcome here like of you if you know we
appreciate you what's passing I reject
those facts I didn't know there was
private property in California it's so
good and it goes on for like an hour so
I recommend whenever you get home I'll
pull it up and watch it the the right is
so much better at trolling than the left
it's outrageous obviously I mean I'll
take a little credit for the blank book
stunts like this are so phenomenal and
we have the troll in chief in the Oval
Office the reason for this though the
reason why this stunt went so well
compare the right wing stunts to the
left wing stunts right wing stunts is a
funny provocative girl shows up to Nancy
Pelosi's house allegedly with illegal
aliens she said that she had illegal
aliens with her I don't know if that's
true or not but it puts Nancy Pelosi in
this awful position of I'm supposed to
arrest them but I said that I can't
arrest them and does she really have
illegal aliens I should let them in but
not the American and what should I do
and so she she goes to Nancy Pelosi's
house and then just engages in funny
repartee it's just funny banter she
didn't kick down Nancy Pelosi's door she
didn't scare Nancy Pelosi's family in
public or
or anything she just engaged in repartee
to explicate how absurd Pelosi's
immigration position is how incoherent
her immigration position is how she
doesn't really believe that walls are
immoral because she has many walls and
security guards herself compare that to
the left what the left does is it sends
roving gangs of thugs to Tucker
Carlson's house kicks in his door breaks
his door has his wife hiding in the
pantry safe room until the cops show up
the lighting up fire in the streets in
Oregon they're just not that funny
now humor requires intelligence and wit
so maybe that would explain some of it
but what it also explains these very
virtues that we're talking about today
with toxic masculinity and with good
virtuous manliness which is Laura Loomer
here is prudent she didn't kick in
anybody's door that wouldn't serve any
purpose she did apparently try Nancy
Pelosi snob said oh that's so weird it's
locked but why is it locked
locks are amoral walls are amoral so she
did was a very prudent she was very
respectful to the police played it
totally straight very humble she goes in
it's not it's not just about her it's
about these ideas
it's about Nancy Pelosi's own words
being used against her everything is in
balance here everything has a sense of
proportion everything has a good sense
of humor really really good stuff I hope
that we get more of this you know we
should never the right should never
engage in what the left does which is go
and scare people and kick in their doors
or anything like that but we should do
this this is terrific to go up to Nancy
Pelosi's gate with and engage in funny
repartee with the security guards that's
terrific that's fabulous
if we had a society like that we would
all be living in wonderful good humor
and we'd all be very grateful for it
nothing threatening nothing mean just
taking the Nancy Pelosi's premises to
their logical conclusion which is that
Laura Loomer should be able to illegally
emigrate onto her property I are asking
her for IDs the entire Democrat Party
tells us that IDs are racist why is this
Democrat speaker of the house why are
her security
asking for a mechanism an instrument of
racism and bigotry because Democrats
don't really believe that IDs are racist
they're just cynical and they're just
race hustling and they're just trying to
divide Americans Laura Loomer showed
that beautifully look my hat is off to
really really well done Kamala Harris
running for president she's put together
a mood mix because as Steve Buscemi says
when he walks in with his skateboard
over his shoulder how do you do fellow
kids hey there fella kids here is Kamala
Harris doing her best rendition of how
do you do fellow kids and this is my
mood mix a song that has always made me
dance
check the rhyme a Tribe Called Quest you
know I'm talking about fight a song that
has to be played loud because you have
to hear the bass the sun is shining by
Bob Marley and the Wailers right the sun
is shining a song that reminds me of
Howard University my alma mater the
mecca the real H you push it by salt and
pepper because it was a real hit song
when I was favorite song from my
childhood young gifted and black by
Aretha Franklin a song that makes me
think of my birthplace Oakland anything
by too short a presidential song for
anyone one nation under our groove by
Funkadelic one nation under agree the
only thing I agree with her on there is
I actually do really like Funkadelic and
I do like one nation under a groove
everything else though how pathetic
let's just go through it because she's
really given us a glimpse into what this
2020 campaign is gonna be like first of
all she's laughing too much in in two
identical away it just seems contrived I
don't know if it's contrived I suspect
it is it's that Hillary thing that haha
I'm likable
look how likeable and casual I am it
doesn't play it also shows that this
entire campaign is going to be going for
identity politics look at what she
highlights she spends a huge portion of
one of the song segments talking about
my alma mater Howard University
historically black the mecca the place
the real hu I think she's referring to
Harvard University although Harvard
doesn't call itself hu but she's drawing
that dichotomy she's saying I'm you know
she says one of her favorite songs Gramp
was young gifted and black see that's me
that's what I was I was born in Oakland
Oakland a very very black very tough
city very tough town
she's smart to do this in a way because
that's her only shot to do anything to
become president she has to play lean
into the intersectionality vibe she has
to play race politics I mean she
actually doesn't she doesn't have to do
it in a in a normal political structure
she's fairly intelligent she's had a
good career she should be able to run on
her own merits but in this day and age
in this Democrat Party she can't do it
the one trouble she's gonna run into on
identity politics is she's not actually
black American in the way we would refer
to that she's half Indian and half
Jamaican her father is a Stanford
economics professor from Jamaica her
mother is a breast cancer scientist so
it really cuts that she's playing it up
as though she grew up in Oakland and you
know rough-and-tumble and young gifted
and black but really she grew up in
total privilege and she didn't grow up
in Oakland at the age of seven she moved
to Canada she moved to Montreal she
lived in Canada until she went to
college and so she totally grew up in
Canada you've got another occasion
cortes thing here she grew up privileged
intelligent half Jamaican half Indian
she's a lawyer who was in Canada and
she's gonna pretend now to have grown up
on the mean streets of Oakland a career
politician who is you were trying to
reinvent her identity to play into what
is unfortunately going to be an identity
politics based Democrat 2020
presidential primary it's too bad for
her she actually does have a lot of
credentials she's had a good career she
could run on the merits if this were any
other time and if she were a member at
any other party but she's not and
I fear for her she's not likable she's
not casual she's she's the poor man's
Alexandria Casio Cortez like the really
poor man's Alexandria okay zo Cortez so
I think she's gonna flop on that point
you know authenticity really matters
these days especially in presidential
politics especially after the age of
Donald Trump or in the age of Donald
Trump and she's going to get hit for in
in authentic representation of her
upbringing it's it's gonna happen it's
not going to come from Republicans it's
gonna come from other Democrats who are
gonna say she's not not the real deal
she's not authentic enough and that's
what you have to look forward to because
a circular firing squad is always
entertaining to watch in politics when
it's your opponent's doing it okay
that's our show we can get to everything
we'll try to get to more tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael gold show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
Audio is mixed by Dylan case production
assistant Nick Sheehan hair and makeup
is by Jesuit Vera the Michael Noel's
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19